for a chance not a handout
just a fair shot at a good job a safe
place to live
and a better life to pass down to their
kids
this is a special place for the biden
family
my daughter ashley a social worker was a
caseworker here
helping young people who are aging out
of foster care
when my son was the attorney general bo
came here right here
to learn more about job training
programs for the those working toward a
ged
or certificate for a good paying job
when i was senator and vice president
there were plenty of econo
economists i had around me to talk about
every aspect of the economy but i always
think about the people who walk through
the doors here
working people white black brown latino
what are they doing are they okay i know
if they're okay
as they walk through these doors the
economy was doing okay
if they weren't okay we weren't doing
well
that's what we should be thinking about
this latest jobs report
but the report reinforces the worst
fears and painful truths the economic
inequities that began before the
downturn
have only worsened under this failed
presidency
when the crisis started we all hope for
a few months of a shutdown would be
followed by a rapid economic turnaround
no one thought they'd lose their job for
good or see small businesses shut down
on moss
that kind of recovery requires
leadership
we didn't have and still don't have and
as a result
economists are starting to call this
recession a
k-shaped recession which is a fancy
phrase
for what's wrong with everything about
trump's presidency
the k means those at the top are saying
things go up
and those in the middle and below are
seeing things go down and get worse
it's no surprise because that root of
this
is the fact that trump has mismanaged
the covet crisis
and that's why it's a k-shaped pandemic
first the president's chaotic chaotic
mismanagement
of the pandemic they're still holding us
back
compared to other major industrial
countries in europe and asia
during the pandemic our unemployment
rate is still more than
double while other nations have only
gone up by half
why because the president has botched
the covert response
botched it badly i've said from the
beginning we can't deal with an economic
crisis
until you beat the pandemic you can't
have an economic comeback when almost a
thousand americans die
each day from covet when the death toll
has reached about two hundred thousand
when more than six million americans
have been infected
when million more worry about getting
sick and dying
as schools and businesses try to reopen
we all know it didn't have to be this
bad it didn't have to be this bad to
begin with if the president just
did his job if he just took the virus
seriously early on in january and
february
as it spread around the globe if he just
took the steps we needed back in march
and april
to institute widespread testing and
tracing
to control the virus if you provided
clear
national scientific based guidance to
state and local authorities
if you just set a good example like
social distancing and wearing a mask
it's not too much to ask
it's almost like he doesn't care he
doesn't affect him
because it doesn't affect him or his
class of friends
anyone with a big enough checkbook can
get rapid tests on demand
if you don't you might have to wait in
line for hours
and wait for weeks to get your result if
you can get them at all
you have the kind of job where you can
work from a laptop at home
remotely risking getting covet
is very small at work this job report
shows that 37 million people
reported teleworking in august but if
you work in an assembly line or checkout
counter or a meat packing plant
or drive a truck or deliver packages
you're much greater risk
and the job report shows that more than
27 million workers
reported that they couldn't work or lost
hours because their employer had to
close
or lost business due to the pandemic
if you can hire a private tutor or have
a live-in child
care you can balance being a parent
and remote schooling if you can't
you have to do your job and be a teacher
all at once
jill and i have held briefings on
reopening school safety two days ago
asking the question is we hear so many
parents call and ask
us
educators who feel like they're in an
impossible situation
what are they supposed to do with our
children
when the president has made it so hard
for schools to reopen safely
what's the alternative when it's
devastating to keep them isolated
from their friends and their support
systems
i also said earlier this week
to the uh shock of many that we lost
more cops this year to covet
than on patrol this reminder
how an already dangerous job law
enforcement has gotten more
dangerous because of trump's
mismanagement
what made jeb what may be just as
shocking is many other jobs
have also become dangerous due to covet
being a health care worker is now more
dangerous than ever
we've lost hundreds of them this year
because they weren't protected from
covent on the job
meat packers more dangerous than ever
so many have died due to getting covert
at work
work for waitresses and waiters and
transit workers
all become more dangerous with so many
dying of coven
ladies and gentlemen no matter what he
says or what he claims
you are not safer in donald trump's
america
you're not safe in donald trump's
america where people are dying at a rate
last seen when americans were fighting
in world war
ii donald trump's malpractice during
this pandemic has made being a working
american
a life-for-death work and while there is
a disproportionate impact on black
latino and asian americans
and native americans working class
communities white working-class
communities are being hit
hard as well opioid deaths for example
are up during the pandemic another
crisis
that trump continues to all but ignore
in the meantime trump and his friends
have strong views about
what the rest of america should do quote
cut unemployment benefits to force
people to go back to their jobs end of
quote
to fund social security and eliminate
obamacare
in the middle of a pandemic and to quote
reopen
public schools without resources or
guidance
reopen main street business without
protection for workers so corporations
can continue to soar
this is their plan second and similarly
the economic pain remains unrelenting
for millions of working people
of every race and background aren't
getting relief they need
meanwhile well if they're doing just
fine
some better than ever this diversion of
fortunes
is unique to any recession in recent
memory
and the painful truth is we just have a
president who just
doesn't see it he doesn't feel it
he doesn't understand he just doesn't
care he thinks if the stock market is up
then everything's fine if his wealthy
friends and donors are doing well
then everything's doing well if
corporations see their evaluations
rising
then they must be hiring
but the best economists know what i know
i've learned growing up in scranton and
clemont delaware up the road
places where folks aren't invested in
the market like wealthy americans
a measure of our economic success is the
quality
of life of the american people
and if your stock soars families teeter
on the brink of hunger and homelessness
and our president calls that success
what does that say about what he values
when you see the world in such a narrow
prison
it's no wonder he doesn't see nearly 30
million americans on unemployment
one in six small businesses are that are
closed right now
he doesn't understand what life is like
for people
walking by their boarded up shops
educators afraid that doing their job
that the job they love will bring the
virus home to the people they love
or a parent searching for health
insurance now that the furlough
has turned into a layoff it's no wonder
he doesn't see
the single mom forced to wait in a
three-hour
food line so for the first time in her
life
so she can feed her family because she's
now part of the one in six households
with children that don't have enough to
eat
he wants us to believe that we're doing
better
to keep it up and not notice that this
remains the worst
economic situation since the great
depression
and our country face the historic
divergence
in our way of life which gets me my
third and final point
and what the american people really need
to understand
all pain and suffering stems from
president
trump's failure to lead his sheer
inability and willingness to bring
people together
he likes to sign executive orders
actions for photo ops
but they're ill-conceived and could do
more harm than good
he says protecting renters from eviction
that's what he's doing
but he's not giving them any support to
pay the rent when it comes due
millions of americans all will be left
with the terrible choice
between eviction and living in the
streets
or paying back rent they simply don't
have
when there was an answer offered and
rejected
he says he's continuing to provide
enhanced employment unemployment
insurance payments
but he cut the amount that everyone on
it received
leaves them on the edge when it runs out
in a few weeks or sooner
he should be doing his job of calling
congressional leaders together
immediately to get a deal and deliver
real results for the american people
this is the first president in the
middle of a crisis i've never seen has
called congress into the oval office
if i were president that's what i do and
i'd get it done like previous presidents
presidents rentals food unemployment
assistance tens of millions struggling
americans
student loan relief small business
support and aid to schools and state
governments
that are going bankrupt and as long as
this pandemic
and the accompanying economic
catastrophe persist
no one no one should have their water or
power cut off
because they can't afford to pay the
bill
bottom line mr president do your job
get off your golf course and out of the
sand bunker
call the leaders together in the oval
office
sit with them and make a deal make a
deal that delivers for working americans
and eases their anxiety and pain
in july i laid out my build back better
plan for an economy that works for
everyone
over the next three weeks i'll be laying
out the sharp contrast
my plan has with the president's
non-plans
i'll be asking american people three
basic questions
who can handle the pandemic who can keep
their promises
and who cares about and will fight for
working families
like the people here at west end
throughout this pandemic
they found their way to keep the center
open safely
and provide for critical services no one
here has been laid off
they adjusted their spaces for social
distancing
they started a lending program to help
local businesses hair salons
and other small businesses they
continued their child care services
which is critical for so many working
families
by pure courage heart and grit they
never
give up and they never give in as to
pursue the full promise for america
that's the story of the people of this
community and this country
that's who we are give ordinary
americans just half a chance
and they never let the country down
they'll do extraordinary things
they'll never let us down unlike the
current president
and unlike the current president i won't
let you down either that's what this
election is about helping people unite
get together and move this country back
in the direction
that we can be there's nothing beyond
our capacity
nothing if we just do it together
i thank you all i now take your
questions
i guess are you calling on people or how
am i i don't have a list so you go ahead
and call
thank you sir uh this morning in
reference to that article in the
atlantic
in a call convened by your campaign
kazurakan said that
uh the comments demonstrated that
president trump's life is a testament to
self
selfless selfishness and that his soul
is that of a coward
you've talked about this as a different
view of how you see the job as
president but when you hear these
remarks suckers losers
recoiling from amputees what does it
tell you about president trump's soul
and the life he leads
i'm going to try to be measured in my
response
if it's true and based on other things
he said i believe the article is true
i'd ask you all the rhetorical question
how do you feel
how would you feel if you had a kid in
afghanistan right now
how would you feel
if you lost a son daughter husband wife
how would you feel for real i know
that's not your job to express that
feeling
but you know you know in your heart you
know in your gut
it's deplorable it's deplorable
as i've said many times i'll say again
these folks are the backbone of america
they're the heart the soul the grit
that's what patriotism is about
i probably
just never been as disappointed in my
whole career
with a leader that i've worked with
president or otherwise
that if the article is true and it
appears to be based on other things he
said
it is absolutely damnable
it is a disgrace
on a somewhat related topic what would
you say to the supporters
of the q a and the people who believe in
that conspiracy
what they think is true about america
that there's
sex trafficking and conspiracy against
the
president trump and what would you say
to president trump for
not rejecting that conspiracy
and the people who believe in it
i've been a big supporter of mental
health
i'd recommend the people who believe it
maybe should take advantage while it
still exists
in the affordable care act it's bizarre
totally bizarre and now
have you guys found that plain load of
people in uniforms and weapons and
flying around i mean you know have you
found them yet
is anybody even from by the way i
respect conservative
and liberal points of view in the press
anybody found that plane
what in god's name are we doing
look at how it makes us look around the
world
it's mortifying it's embarrassing and
it's dangerous
it's dangerous
if the president doesn't know better
which i he has to
know better and my lord we're in much
more trouble than i ever thought we were
it's bizarre and
you know this is the case where
you know i i've been surprised pleased
but surprised
with folks i've had political arguments
with like the former governor of
michigan
coming out and endorsed me all the
republicans are endorsing me
they're they're rich where i am
that this can't go on
this cannot go on
it's a deconstruction of a democratic
system
they know it
so i just um
i'll conclude with what you heard me say
many times before
the words of a president matter
even a lousy president it gives
soccer it gives encouragement
to people who are spouting irrational
views that no one has even close to
ever presuming or showing ever existed
and it's done for a simple reason
from the very beginning he's understood
the only way he could win the first time
and can win this time
is he fundamentally divides the nation
puts the nation divides us or in each
other's throats
that's not who we are
that's not who we are
thank you
thank you mr vice president last night
president trump
mocked you for wearing a mask and said
that this is a sign that you must have
some quote
big issues he says this even though he
knows that
according to scientists and public
health officials wearing masks
saves lives i wonder if you worry that
this kind of language that comes from
the president
of the united states could deter some
americans who are tuning in to him
to not wear masks well
i i worry frieza is a big issue i'm a
smart fella
i listen to scientists this is not a
game
life and death
life and death reports that we're going
to have
maybe there's some reports there's
another 100 000 dead as many as 100 000
dead
more by the end of the year i mean i
don't
i i don't get it i mean
i i just anyway i
i it's it's hard to respond to something
so idiotic
okay um before my second question just
quickly have you been tested now for
cobin 19 yes i had
how many times i've been tested once
with the deep test and i'm going to
continue to be testing
on a regular basis um could i just ask
quickly about
attorney general william barr saying on
cnn this week
he said that his assessment right now uh
is that china poses the most aggressive
threat to u.s elections
even more than iran or russia uh do you
believe him is that also your
understanding based on the intelligence
briefings that you have received
no it's not consistent with the
briefings i've received and uh
he's a lousy enough attorney general but
he's a really bad intelligence officer
it's not consistent because you believe
because i believe what
i've been told and you all know it
i mean look it's uh you even have
outfits like facebook
taking some hey look it's just
there are a lot of countries around the
world i think would be happy to see our
elections destabilized
but the one who's working the hardest
most consistently
and never has led up is russia
and again it's unfair to say to you guys
but ask yourself the rhetorical question
what is he so afraid
of vladimir putin
i mean what what's the problem
i mean nothing nothing
it's almost obsequious
i mean anyway
i uh
i just want to make it clear
i believe any country
engages in any activity
to delegitimize our impact on american
elections
is a direct violation of our sovereignty
and if i impress united states there
will be a response
thank you
sir uh it's been a couple weeks now
since you announced senator harris as
your running mate and we haven't seen
her out very much including yesterday in
kenosha
why is that and and what role do you see
here playing in the
in the final she's been on the road
she's out herself
the role is that just like when barack
and i campaigned
we tried to cover as much territory as
we could and
both of us out campaigning she is an
incredibly
competent candidate she is doing a great
job
there will be times we're together but
there's a lot of territory to cover
i talk with her almost every day i speak
with her we work together
and i have great confidence there's
nothing about not campaigning together
it's about being able to cover more
territory
and just as a second question um do you
know when you will have another
covet test do you have any plan any
future testing
well what they're doing is they're going
to do it on a regular basis because
everyone on the on my service detail and
people who come into
the house with me they're all attested
so i'm just doing i just
yes sir show up and put my head back you
know
when they tell me you don't know where
it'll be next one pardon me
you don't know where the next one will
be well i know i imagine it'll be
sometime this week i just don't know i
but every regular basis thank you
thank you sir um he asked you about
another thing the president said last
night he
once again suggested to his supporters
that they should consider voting twice
if they're in one of those states that
can allow you to request an absentee
ballot to fill that out and then go
try voting again in person state
officials have said it's a felony
in some cases just curious what you make
of it
it is it is a felony you're feeling here
in the state of delaware
look i mean how many times
does this president have to suggest
things and say things
we all don't just write he's a fraud
not not being not not an opinion
he wanted to maybe we should delay the
election
maybe we should you know write in
ballots are
are are fraudulent not a single bit of
evidence this i mean
it just is and i think it's all designed
to create so much chaos
that no matter what the outcome of the
election is that it's thrown up in the
air
i mean i think that must be his reason
because
i mean he says and does things that um
no other president said i'm aware of
and american history's ever done and we
all go well
there's another ridiculous illegal
inappropriate thing he said but we say
so many of them
it doesn't matter i mean
it is uh it's just
it just undermines the legitimacy
of our democratic process and it's
dangerous
you said today is the angriest youth
you've been
as a presidential candidate
um but you said you're trying to
restrain yourself is there a lot of
people out there who are
supporting you or inclined to not vote
for the president who would say
why isn't joe biden angrier about all of
this
because presidents united states should
be presidential
and should lead by example
as well as make clear exactly where they
stand
getting down in the gutter like the
president does
saying things that i'd be inclined if we
were behind a barn somewhere
would be a different thing but that's
not the job of a president
the job of a president sets an example
my anger is real because i must tell you
i carry and i deliberately didn't bring
with me today
delaware national guard had a pin made
up
that's a gold star that was made up for
my son beau who didn't die
in the field and i always carry it with
me
and i didn't carry today because
i was
worried that if i focus too much on it
that i would uh engage in
some of the kind of language the
president has used
i mean but i just think it is sick
it is deplorable it is so
unamerican it is so
unpatriotic
and then watching him this morning
while i was shaving the tv on
talking about he never said anything
like that he honored john mccain
he's the reason why flags were flown at
half mask
oh wasn't that noble of him he's the
same guy
that when the ship went into harbor he
made sure the uss mccain was covered
you couldn't see it he's the same guy
that denigrated john he's the same
guy who did a similar thing the way he
talked about george h.w bush was shot
down
in the pacific i mean but he just stands
there
it's almost pathological i've never said
anything like that
no one's been better than the military
i i i just got to focus on
what has to be done not what he did what
i do from here what gets done from here
thank you sir
thank you mr vice president if i could
follow up on ed's question about voting
we know the president has been attacking
mail and voting he's even now suggesting
his supporters vote twice we also know
that russia has been trying to so doubt
about this system
are you concerned at all that this
messaging may be working that your
support supporters may give
up on voting by mail because they're
concerned that it may be raped
yes i am that's why i try not to talk
about it too much
because i'm playing into we're playing
the more we talk about there's two
things he wants us to talk about
is the election legitimate and
the whole country's up in flames
everything's burning law and order
because he doesn't want to talk about
anything anything at all
about the job he hasn't done
and so it is it's a conundrum
there's a lot you could talk about in
terms of the specifics
that russia is doing and not doing but
when you do it all it does is undermine
what people think may be the legitimate
what i don't want to have happen
i don't want people reaching the point
where you can understand sometimes
it's not worth voting
you know it seems to me that one of the
things that i keep
trying to say to people is go to
iwillvote.com
figure out iwillvote.com
and figure out where you can vote how
you can vote
what's available to you where you can
vote early
where you can vote in person where it's
going to be safe for you etc
plan now plan now
but the more chaos it is sown here
it's going to disincline people to show
up
and in a sense i every time i speak
about i feel like i'm playing at his
game
i mean is that not to agree with me does
that make sense what i'm saying that's
what i'm
so i think that's all part of the deal
thank you mr vice president um going
back to the jobless report from this
morning
you had acknowledged that less than half
of the 22 million jobs that were lost
this spring because of pandemic have
been recovered
what do you think the 1.4 million added
back
in august says about just the general
direction of the economy
i think any job at it act is positive
i think it matters to the people who got
that job back
you know maybe you all were raising
households
like i was where a mom or dad
was losing a job because of the economy
what's going on in your community
you could feel the tension on these in
the household how it just everything
you know worrying about what you can
provide for your family
and along the way also look at the
people who
you've got you know a couple million
people out there close to
who are part-time workers
still can't make it but are
are listed as employed and
a lot of them also are in the process of
wondering whether or not
i mean there are a lot of people line up
in food lines
they're the people many of them who have
lost their their uh
their employ their health care their
their health care provided by their
employer there are
many they're the same people are out
there worrying if this president is able
to
win in court and wipe out the entire
affordable care act
and all the 100 million people with
pre-existing conditions won't be able to
get insurance even if they had the money
and i mean
it's just the anxiety is enormous
is enormous and look again i'm not
being solicitous
among the brightest people i've dealt
with my whole career
have been the press not a joke
you're all extremely well educated
you're well read
have significant backgrounds and
um
and the vast majority have tried to
report the news
not just opinion but
i can't believe
that you don't feel the same not
democrat republican okay
you don't feel the same anxiety because
you got a brother or sister a mother a
father
a son or a daughter who's going through
what you're not we're not we have jobs
well i don't have a job now but we have
jobs
and so it's it's a real concern and uh
i just think that this has moved beyond
democrat republican i think has moved to
uh
um trying to put this country
back together again so we can move thank
you
the president trump has just announced
the kosovo and serbia deal and as part
president trump has just announced uh an
economic normalization deal between
serbia and kosovo
and part of that deal is kosovo and
israel
having diplomatic normalization
you have stated that you support a
two-state solution in the middle east
would you support more muslim-majority
countries
normalizing relations with israel even
though it may mean that the palestinians
will lose
leverage in their fight towards a
two-state solution
well first of all i'm not i don't know
what the deal is
you're referring to okay what i have
argued
relative to serbia and kosovo
is that kosovo should be
an independent country not
a part of serbia i've spent a lot of
time there and so i don't know how
i assume that would reinforce that
independence but i don't know based on
what's being said
i think normalization of
relations among countries is a
by and large and almost every instance a
good
thing to have a muslim
majority country normalizing relations
with israel in a generic sense
seems positive to me but i have to know
the detail of what's happening
what's going on and i don't know
that and it may you may be right that
that would cause the palestinians to
lose
leverage in a decision on a two-state
solution
more countries recognizing israel
oh i do absolutely i do
i do and i think that's the thing
recognizing israel as an independent
jewish
state i think that's important and
but but also i believe that israel has
to be prepared
to work toward a genuine two-state
solution thank you all very much